[MUSIC PLAYING]
DANA BOEBINGER:
I'm Dana Boebinger,
a neuroscientist at the
McGovern Institute, at MIT.
I study perception,
or how the brain
uses the senses to understand
the world around us.
When your senses are
activated, your brain
is sent clues about what's
out there in the world.
Usually, your senses
give you lots of clues,
and your brain pieces
these clues together
to figure out the
complete picture.
But sometimes, the
clues aren't so clear,
and your brain has to
make a guess about what's
out there based on your brain's
assumptions or expectations.
So if you change
your expectations,
you can actually
change your perception.
Here's what I mean.
I'm going to play
a sound, and I want
you to listen for this word.
You probably heard brainstorm.
Now, I'm going to play
the exact same sound,
but I want you to
listen for these words.
You probably heard the words
green needle this time.
That's because the audio quality
of this clip isn't clear,
and your brain
made an assumption
based on the clues it was given.
You can visit our website to
experience other illusions
and learn more about perception.